excuses excuses vice president kamala
harris dishing up plenty of blame and
reasons on why she hasn't visited the
southern border
33 days since president biden appointed
her as the crisis point person
are you going to go there in that regard
it is yes we're working on the plan to
get there we have to deal with covet
issues but
i can't get there soon enough in terms
of personally getting there
it's not going to be solved overnight
it's a complex issue
listen if this were easy it would have
been handled years ago
we're making progress but it's not going
to evidence itself overnight
it will not but it will be worth it
but the american people know exactly
who's to blame
voters in a new fox poll say border
security is worse today
than it was two years ago and guess
what's actually making an appearance at
the border
copies of the vp's 2019 children's book
handed out to kids at a shelter along
the southern border in california
harris's office saying they weren't
aware of these welcome packs
and that they're usually organized by
members of the community
while dana imagine if trump gave art of
the deal to kids in cages
i just cannot i can't even see what they
would say about that
um i don't know it's kind of silly when
you think about it
right what do you think is going on here
i i
am really just surprised at all of this
um i'll tell you why
so um if you recall vice president
harris was given this
point made the point person on the
border the day after she laughed at a
question when she was asked about going
to the border
so it seems to me that they
over-corrected
on a pr issue that they could have
handled and now they have a much bigger
pr issue because she clearly doesn't
want to really deal with it
and you know they when they say that you
know superheroes are everywhere but
they're not at the border apparently
because
this issue to me a vice president would
one want to take on a big issue like
this
and also the administration is taking on
so much water
and negativity when it comes to the
border issue as you saw in that poll and
then all the other polls and it's just
obvious on its face and i'm starting to
feel like
you know she had this moment in these
first 100 days
and it was different it was new and when
you see on wednesday night when she is
sitting there with nancy pelosi
um and biden is giving the speech that
will be historic that is a moment
but then what are you doing with that
moment where are you stepping up and i
feel like there's that i just really
feel like that has been lacking well
degan she says she can't get down to the
northern triangle because of covid
she's been vaccinated i'm sure the
presidents of those countries have been
vaccinated but that's now just a
convenient excuse
right and what message does that send to
the border personnel and the volunteers
at the border
and well quite frankly people working in
hospitals
for more than the last year and grocery
store workers who put their lives on the
line
this is a lose-lose for vice president
harris in two ways
because she's clearly being fed this oh
blame covid don't go to the border yet
and then these books magically show up
in welcome
welcome gift bags for children so that
makes her if
like she looks like she's not in charge
so she's weak
or on the other hand she just doesn't
want to be photographed with a bunch of
suffering children and that makes her
look
uncaring so she can't get out of this
but they're craving the body
administration they're craving poll
watchers
if these numbers keep declining they
will make a chain and
change it fast remember what they did
last summer they didn't say
buckets about the riots that were raging
in cities across the
country and they only spoke out about it
after the poll numbers started moving
against them
that is true one i have to give credit
where credit is due biden saw this
coming
and he said here kamal you take it and
now we're doing a segment on kamala hare
1600
you know chewing gum or doing whatever
he's doing
well no i i think what we saw in the
poll numbers indicated that
immigration is a real problem for the
biden administration he's the president
jesse
and he's getting hit on that subject i
mean he's he's got to come up with some
ideas now
i don't buy into this idea that simply
making a photo op
at the border is the key to the solution
i mean gosh if that's the case then
senator cruz senator lankster i think
congressman mccarthy they've all been
down on the border we don't have any
solution
as a result of their magical photo op
taking selfies i think they were trying
to exploit the issue for political
advantage so i think that the the
reality
is that you know when you look at the
steps that they are taking that kamala
harris and president biden are taking i
think they're real steps they're trying
to
improve border security and you've seen
the arrest the apprehensions
up markedly you've seen an improvement
in terms of the asylum
process with more judges put in place so
that it can be more speedy
you see increased cooperation now coming
from mexico
and i think that's a breakthrough you
also see them trying to establish
processing places for people who want
asylum refugees who
are seeking asylum in their home
countries or
outside the united states this but i
think the big thing is giving aid
to some of these countries and saying
people don't want to leave home
uh they'd rather stay but they're
suffering from you know
violence economic devastation uh
tornadoes and the like let's let's let's
look at this realistically and i think
you take
gradual steps yeah well
realistically we've been giving aid for
years and that hasn't always worked greg
i would have given the plus to these
kids
coming across let's get them started
here absolutely they would learn
far so much more by the way i do agree
with juan
apprehension is up on the border and uh
mexico was already cooperating with
america so it wasn't a breakthrough
trump had already had that covered
we also learned how to do those photo
ops from aoc
who was down at the border crying her
eyes out if you if you remember that
um i just think it's this whole thing
was a desperate ploy
to get free publicity for a new book you
know she couldn't do a book signing at
borders
so she went to the border that's a joke
about a bookstore that no longer exists
so for you young people it used to be uh
that but
i really here's the interesting story
and i
uh i didn't see this coming but she is
revealing herself to be not very good at
this
not very good at this job in general and
this could be why she failed miserably
in the primary
because she was the media's pick not the
people's pick
i picked her i thought that she was
actually going to be the nominee
and then i was sure that she was going
to be the vp but that's i'm in the media
that was the choice would i what i
thought i saw
was that oh this person might be
charming and interesting and ticks all
the boxes
but she's actually like a i thought that
she could be the backup qb but she's
like the third string punter
and when she shows up at these things
you feel like she's in over her
head and it's compounded by the kind of
the the the laughter and the nervousness
she reminds me of a co-worker
that is not up for the job and when
you're in a meeting
it's just like every time she talks or
he talks it's just a cringe moment
and the dog knock barking obviously is
the media that just like knows it too
uh they thought that this was gonna be
the next president
well i think everybody on your staff
knows exactly who that
employee is that you're talking about at
the meetings